times new roman is the default typeface
for everything we see from term papers
and congress to movie posters and books
but why is times new roman the default
typeface
times new roman is economical it is a
relatively cheap typeface to print out
compared to other typefaces
it was also right around this time that
more students began writing by computers
than writing by hand or typewriter
most computers released around this time
included times new roman due to its wide
licensing deals with monotype and lana
type licensing is a huge way to get your
type out there if it's not available to
the masses
it can't be used so because times new
roman was inexpensive to license
cheap to print involved and highly
legible it became the default typeface
on most word processing programs like
microsoft word and macro
so an entire generation grew up using
this typeface not by choice but because
it was the font given to you to start
with
and what everyone came to be used to so
these days times new roman is no longer
the system default but its impression on
culture
has made it an expressive design choice
rather than an economic system default
so the default isn't always the best at
everything
but it's usually the one with the least
amount of drama
[Music]